hello youtubers my name is Van Jones I'm
with an organization called green for
all we're a sister organization for the
Ella Baker Center for Human Rights in
the United States of America I think the
one thing that we all need to be focused
on is building a green economy that is
strong enough to lift millions of people
out of poverty the the two big issues
that are going to be with us are going
to be the incredible ecological crisis
that we're in the ecological destruction
and then also the social crisis the
widening gap between rich and poor in
all of our countries and all around the
world well though that you slightly
different problems but there's one
solution and that solution is to build a
green economy that's strong enough to
lift people out of poverty we're focused
on the question of green collar jobs
we're working to get green collar jobs
for low-income people idea is we have
all this work to be done to retrofit the
way we do energy all around the world
there are millions of buildings that
need to be weatherize there are millions
of solar panels need to get put up
there's millions of wind farms and solar
farms and wave forms they need to be
built so we can have energy without
destroying the planet that's a lot of
work and there are millions of people
who don't have work I believe the moral
challenge of the new century is to
connect the people who most need work to
the work that most needs to be done and
that way we can fight poverty and
pollution at the same time if you are an
entrepreneur business person you should
be going green you should be going green
and clean you also should be thinking
about how can when you use the fact that
we have all this work to be done now and
to do it in a different way to employ
people maybe you have an employee before
the delicate of the ladder out of
poverty we need green pathways out of
poverty and into prosperity into
community and to dignity this is
possible through the business community
saying we are going to deal with this
problem on both sides of it we're going
to be more fair toward our workers were
going to be more fair toward communities
that were involved in we're going to
adhere to highest things with regard to
labor and with regard to the environment
the key role for business and then as
far as government is concerned the
governments around the world right now
our partners mainly to the problem
makers in the world their partners to
the warmongers of polluters incarcerated
to people who are doing destructive
things the governments of the world need
to get on the side of the
problem solvers in the world on the Eco
entrepreneurs a solar industry that the
coaches and the counselors and teachers
and the artists of people all around the
world who are trying to make a
difference but you feel like it's all
uphill if the governments of the world
were problems to the problem solvers in
the business community and the problem
solvers at the community level we would
be able see a green wave a green wave
that can lift all boats definitely shot
be focused on thank you I'm then